eine kleine Macke Ring gemacht und diese
Macke
ich habe hier eine kleine Macke seht ihr
sie
ich mache das einfach so
ich habe auch eine Macke nicht nur die
Torte
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute ist der 4 Dezember das ist der
zweite Advent und wenn ihr den
Adventskalender habt öffnet ihr heute
Tür Nummer 4 wenn ihr den Kalender nicht
habt habt ihr trotzdem einen
wunderschönen Tag denn heute ist Sonntag
und wenn ihr die Tür Nummer 4 habt dann
entdeckt ihr darin das heutige Türchen
nämlich
ich hoffe ich verrate jetzt nicht so
viel also falls ihr den Kalender noch
nicht geöffnet habt und es heute Abend
machen wolltet solltet ihr ihn
vielleicht doch jetzt öffnen denn das
ganze passt auch ganz gut zum Frühstück
denn es ist ein Fruchtaufstrich von Bonn
Marmore ihr kennt vielleicht alle von
Mama vom Supermarkt das ist nämlich eine
Marke die viele Fruchtaufstriche
Konfitüre und Marmeladen herstellt und
ich muss zugeben umgangssprachlich nennt
man so gut wie alles Marmelade also für
mich war immer alles Erdbeermarmelade
Himbeermarmelade und ich habe nicht so
wirklich auf das Wording geachtet aber
es gibt doch einen Unterschied eine
Marmelade besteht nämlich zu 60% aus
Zucker und ein Fruchtaufstrich wie
dieser z.B der hier auch ganz fein
passiert ist der besteht zumindestens 50
bis 64% aus Früchten das heißt es ist
weniger süß es ist einfach sehr lecker
das ganze ist vor allem passiert das
heißt man hat da diese Kerne nicht mit
dabei und keine Fruchtstückchen denn ich
weiß dass viele Fruchtstückchen nicht
mögen deswegen passieren wir immer
unsere him und die Erdbeeren für die
ganzen Rezepte und ich muss sagen dass
Bonn Marmor für mich so eine Marke ist
die einfach toll ist weil sie so
selfmade aussieht also es sieht halt aus
wenn man sich das so anschaut als hätte
ich die Marmelade selbst gekocht da
karierte Deckel ist ganz typisch und
auch das Etikett finde ich nicht so es
ist einfach nicht so industriell und
nicht so werblich wie so andere Marken
und das sieht einfach so handmade aus
als hätte ich es halt selber in der
Küche zubereitet oder die Oma irgendwie
daheim aus ihren Erdbeeren die sie noch
da hatte und genauso schmeckt eben auch
und hier habt ihr jetzt mal die Sorte
Erdbeere fein passiert Aprikose fein
passiert und auch noch Kirsche fein
passiert es wird mir wahrscheinlich
trotzdem innerhalb dieses Videos immer
mal wieder passieren dass ich sage jetzt
nehmt ihr die Marmelade aber wie gesagt
das ist ein Fruchtaufstrich und keine
Marmelade aber umgangssprachlich nennen
wir das halt irgendwo alle immer gleich
ich muss dazu sagen dass ich ein großer
Fan bin von butterbrötchen mit Marmelade
oder mit Fruchtaufstrich was sich z.B
mit der Erdbeere ganz gerne mache
Erdbeer Konfitüre oder Erdbeer
Fruchtaufstrich ist so mein Favorit
Himbeer natürlich auch
Aprikose benutze ich ganz gerne für mein
Buchteln also wenn ihr ein buchtelrezept
habt wenn ihr Buchteln zubereiten wollt
nach meinem Rezept dann am besten
Aprikose nehmen fallen passiert die ist
der Hammer ich finde es Buchteln mit
Aprikose wirklich sensationell und ich
werde heute für mein Rezept Kirsche
verwenden weil ich heute eine
weihnachtliche Torte zubereiten möchte
das ganze soll eine adventstorte sein
die ihr aber auch an zubereiten könnt
als Weihnachtstorte die ohne Fondant
auskommt und einfach eine schöne
winterliche weihnachtliche Dekoration
hat deswegen werde ich jetzt dafür auch
einen Lebkuchenteig Backen es kommt eine
leckere Buttercreme und dann eben das
ganze aufgepeppt mit dem Fruchtaufstrich
von Bon Marmore weil er eben nicht ganz
so süß ist und perfekt geschmacklich mit
reinpasst ich muss nichts mehr fein
passieren und kann das Ganze eben super
zum Backen verwenden wo ihr den
Fruchtaufstrich auch verwenden könnt ist
zum Beispiel beim Plätzchen backen weil
man gerade dabei Hilda Brötchen oder bei
eben anderen Plätzchen die gefüllt
werden sollen auch immer fein passierte
Konfitüren oder Fruchtaufstriche nimmt
weil man da eben diese störenden
Fruchtstückchen nicht haben will und
auch die Kerne das heißt man kann sie
super in Spritzbeutel füllen und eben
alles damit befüllen und perfekt ihr
habt übrigens in der Tür auch einen
Rabattgutschein falls ihr die Marmelade
eben nachbestellen wollt gut also die
packe ich jetzt zur Seite nee die
Kirsche benutze ich Aprikose und
Erdbeere packe ich zur Seite die sind
fürs Frühstück und ihr könnt mein Quark
einrühren also da ich finde bei
Fruchtaufstrichen da gibt es einfach so
vielerlei Möglichkeiten sie einzusetzen
und eben nicht nur aufs Butterbrot die
packe ich zur Seite und dann richtig
hier jetzt die Zutaten für den Boden
und die Adventskalendertürchen immer
schön wieder verschließen wieder hier
reinpacken und wenn euer Adventskalender
am Ende des Monats leer ist könnt ihr
diesen nämlich einfach verwenden und im
nächsten Jahr einen eigenen
Adventskalender machen einfach die
Türchen befüllen und Verschenken oder
zum Beispiel so ein Baby Karton draus
machen als Baby Geschenk
Hochzeitsgeschenk Flitterwochen Karton
da gibt's so viele Ideen und
Möglichkeiten die zeige ich euch alle
noch nicht wegschmeißen und das Glas
später auch nicht wegschmeißen da kann
man nämlich auch schöne die Eiweiß damit
machen
aber jetzt backen wir erstmal okay
für den Rührteig verwende ich 6 Eier
300g Zucker etwas Salz und Tonka Paste
zwei Esslöffel Lebkuchengewürz jeweils
300 ml Sonnenblumenöl und Kinderpunsch
oder in dem Glühwein 450 Gramm Mehl plus
ein Päckchen Backpulver oder wird mein
backmehl da ist es schon enthalten 50 g
Kakao und 200 g Mandeln die werden
gleich noch gemahlen das denn jetzt mal
die Grundzutaten ich finde es sieht auf
den ersten Blick immer nach ganz viel
aus aber es ist im Prinzip eigentlich
gar nicht ihr nehmt jetzt erstmal die
Eier den Zucker das Salz und die Tonka
Paste und verrührt die Zutaten richtig
schön weiß cremig und ich kann in der
Zwischenzeit einfach schon mal den
Mandeln feinmalen
[Musik]
so sieht die Masse jetzt perfekt aus ich
habe jetzt hier die Mandeln schon gemalt
dann kann ich das Sonnenblumenöl und den
Kinderpunsch dazugeben und die Zutaten
kurz einrühren
dann habt ihr eine saubere Küche
das Mehl muss ich jetzt nicht sieben
weil mein backmehl ist das ist schon
ganz fein aber das Kakaopulver gebe ich
jetzt hier dazu das ist nämlich immer so
ein bisschen klumpig und das
Lebkuchengewürz
ich nehme einfach noch ein bisschen Mehl
um das restliche Kakaopulver
herauszukriegen
dann kommen die trockenen Zutaten hier
rein und werden nur ganz kurz eingerührt
ich habe meinen Ofen schon vorgeheizt
ich backe das Ganze gleich in vier
backringen ihr könnt aber auch einfach
nur zwei nehmen ich mache es in vier
damit einfach die Backzeit etwas kürzer
ist aber zwei backringe gehen auch und
wenn ihr nur einen besitzt dann solltet
ihr erst die Hälfte des Teiges machen
und dann später noch mal die Hälfte
damit der Teig hier nicht in der Küche
rum steht
denn ich möchte ja eine schöne hohe
Torte ihr könnt es aber auch vom
Durchmesser her einfach größer machen
und so ein bisschen flacher machen
also hier sind die vier backringe alle
auf 20 cm und weil es ein recht
flüssiger Teig ist solltet ihr die
backringe entweder den Backpapier
einschlagen oder so einen
Springformboden darunter verwenden dann
läuft da auf jeden Fall nichts aus
so perfekt ist es wenn ihr hier auch so
eine Innenskalierung habt dann seht ihr
nämlich dass der Teig gleichmäßig
eingefüllt wird ich habe jetzt bei zwei
in Skalierung und zwei ist zwei zwei
habe ich noch das alte Modell aber ist
nicht schlimm ich will das jetzt hier
rein und dann wird der Kuchen gebacken
alle vier perfekt aufgeteilt ihr könnt
sie jetzt im vorgeheizten Ofen bei 170
Grad ober Unterhitze Backen immer zwei
Stück gleichzeitig die anderen zwei
packe ich da rein wenn ihr einen Ofen
nur besitzt könnt ihr auch gerne bei
Heißluft backen da könnt ihr auch viel
auf einmal backen aber ich bin bei
rührteigen und bei Kuchen immer eher der
Fan von ober Unterhitze weil Heißluft
den Teig oder den Kuchen eben ausdrucken
kann
[Musik]
ich mache die Backbleche auch immer gern
so umgedreht da rein dann habe ich eine
gerade Fläche und kann die Backbleche
Backformen einfach so da reinschieben
ohne eine Stolperkante
Spaß
[Musik]
mache ich jetzt sauber
die Kuchenböden sind gebacken und
bereits im Kühlschrank und ich habe
jetzt in der Zwischenzeit auch schon mal
gezuckerte Cranberries vorbereitet dazu
gibt es bereits ein Video auf meinem
Kanal und ich habe es euch auch noch mal
extra als Shorts gefilmt denn dann nehme
ich einfach Cranberries dafür koche
etwas Zucker mit Wasser auf zu einem
Zuckersirup der Zuckersirup wird dann
vom Herd runter genommen damit ein
bisschen abkühlt dann werden die
Cranberries darin gewälzt und später
eben zum Trocknen entweder in den
Backofen gegeben bei Heißluft oder in
der Automaten für eine Stunde bei 60
Grad das ist wirklich perfekt
anschließend müssen sie dann nämlich nur
noch den Zucker gewälzt werden und dann
habt ihr einfach eine richtig schöne
Dekoration die gut schmeckt gut auf
Torten passt oder auf anderes Gebäck und
es ist hervorragend ich habe jetzt hier
schon mal Zutaten für meine Creme ihr
könnt gerne die Torte mit einer
Mascarpone Creme oder Quarkcreme machen
allerdings finde ich das jetzt hier eine
Buttercreme perfekt passt ihr könnt die
italienische Buttercreme machen oder die
Schweizer Buttercreme also die Swiss
Buttercreme die besteht einfach nur aus
Eiweiß Zucker und Butter die ist der
Hammer ich liebe die Schweizer
Buttercreme ihr könnt aber auch so wie
jetzt hier die französische Buttercreme
machen die besteht nämlich aus ganzem
Eiern also wenn ihr sagt die
eiweißbuttercreme möchte ich jetzt nicht
damit ich kein Eigelb übrig habe könnt
ihr gerne französische machen allerdings
muss ich sagen dass die französische
Buttercreme so einen leichten Gelbstich
hat also nicht ganz so weiß und perfekt
weiß wird wie die
Swiss Buttercreme ich habe jetzt hier
auch mein Grundrezept noch mal
abgewandelt und werde euch das noch mal
erneut auf den Block stellen und in die
App und auch dazu gibt's dann ein
eigenes Shorts für die französische
Buttercreme verwende ich drei Eier 100 g
Zucker etwas Salz 400 g weiche Butter
100 g Puderzucker und zum Verfeinern
etwas Vanilleextrakt und orangenpaste
und jetzt nimmt ihr die Eier mit Zucker
und Salz und nimmt entweder einen Topf
mit Wasser drin und eine Schüssel oben
drauf und verrührt das ganze über dem
kochenden Wasserbad oder ihr nehmt
einfach eine Küchenmaschine mit
hitzefunktion und ver hier die Zutaten
für etwa 10 Minuten bei 70 Grad
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
die
Schweizer Baisermasse
das reicht auf jeden Fall gehe aber hier
auf 70 Grad und das Erhitzen bewirkt
dass die Eier quasi pasteurisiert werden
die Salmonellen werden abgetötet falls
welche vorhanden werden ihr wisst ja
Salmonellen sitzen immer auf der
Eierschale und nicht dem Eier innen das
ist immer ganz wichtig zu wissen und so
sorgt man einfach dafür dass sie
pasteurisiert werden sie werden erhitzt
und dann werden sie auch richtig schön
stabil und die Buttercreme ist einfach
länger haltbar
wenn die Butter dann mit dem Puderzucker
richtig schön cremig verrührt ist könnt
ihr jetzt die abgekühlte Eiermasse
dazugeben und einfach schön cremig
weiter rühren
jetzt habe ich hier die fertigen Böden
die lassen sich auch ganz einfach
rauslösen
sehr gut und wenn sie gleichmäßig hoch
gebacken sind müsst ihr sie nicht einmal
schneiden ich sehe nur bei dem einen der
ist nicht ganz gleichmäßig jetzt ein
bisschen
dann nehme ich hier eine Ganache die hat
20 cm im Durchmesser da kommt jetzt der
erste Boden drauf
jetzt könnt ihr entweder mit Paletten
arbeiten und das ganze schön
aufstreichen oder auch mit einem
Spritzbeutel zum Beispiel da könnt ihr
es dann nämlich so machen dass die
Buttercreme direkt gleichmäßig
aufgestrichen wird als ich muss das
sagen die französische Buttercreme hier
die ist sehr gut sehr cremig aber die
ist auch buttriger als die Schweizer
Buttercreme so auf die Buttermenge
bezogen
und dann trage ich jetzt hier eine dünne
Schicht auf
[Musik]
dann kommt da jetzt ein kleiner Ring
drumherum
und hier in die Mitte kommt jetzt ein
Pool aus Marmelade was ich bei den
Fruchtaufstrichen von Bon Marmore ganz
toll findet die kommen wirklich auch
ohne Konservierungsstoffe aus ohne
Farbstoffe und schmecken trotzdem
wunderbar lecker und haben alle eine
richtig richtig tolle Farbe und ich
finde gerade die Kirsche hier passt halt
perfekt aber auch Aprikose Himbeere
Erdbeere wird auch super passen dann
kommt jetzt da der zweite Boden drauf
und genau so füllt ihr dann die gesamte
Torte
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der letzte Boden da achte
ich immer drauf dass ich einen schönen
geraden Abschluss mache das heißt immer
den Boden einfach einmal umdrehen und
dann habt ihr wirklich die perfekte
Torte die schön gerade ist
der Teigkarte hier noch mal kurz
streichen
das sieht schon mal ziemlich gut aus
wobei hier jetzt
dann kommt da die zweite ganachingplatte
drauf wobei das mache ich jetzt gleich
ich packe jetzt erstmal ein die Torte
wird jetzt nämlich erst meine
Kühlschrank gestellt da kann ich es
gleich noch ein bisschen drücken dass er
nicht schief ist ich nehme dafür meine
tortenrandfolie die ist auch mehrmals
verwendbar die wasche ich einfach immer
wieder ab nach dem Gebrauch
so die sieht eigentlich zu lang aber das
macht nichts ich will jetzt nicht kürzer
schneiden damit ich sie später auch bei
größeren Torten wieder verwenden kann
so sieht die Torte schon mal gut aus ich
finde sie riecht auch schon gut die
lebkuchenböden riecht man gut raus die
Kirschmarmelade ist der Hammer und die
wird der Torte einfach so dieses diesen
fruchtigen tollen Geschmack geben und
dann noch die Buttercreme dazu ich
glaube das wird eine richtig gute Torte
die kommt jetzt aber erstmal in den
Kühlschrank für ungefähr zwei Stunden
eine Stunde reicht auch schon aus aber
wenn ihr sie zwei Stunden kühl stellt
wisst ihr einfach später die Torte ist
bombenfest und ihr könnt sie perfekt
dekorieren die Buttercreme lasse ich bei
Raumtemperatur liegen nicht in den
Kühlschrank packen denn die brauche ich
ja später noch weich zum Verstreichen
ein Streichen und dekorieren
jetzt ist die Torte gut gekühlt und ihr
könnt sie komplett mit der restlichen
Buttercreme bestreichen wow
also ein bisschen was werde ich schon
noch überbehalten für die Dekoration
aber jetzt wird erst einmal der Rand
dekoriert bzw gestrichen
so einfach Spritzbeutel oben ansetzen
und dann bis nach unten
ich finde es immer ein bisschen
einfacher
und dann könnte so einen Teigkarte
nehmen
und drumherum
[Musik]
wenn ich dann den Rand der Torte
abgezogen habt könnt ihr die Oberfläche
mit der Creme bestreichen
und jetzt noch die Oberfläche also
einmal hier von außen nach innen sehen
sehr gut
noch eine kleine Änderung und dann kommt
die Torte noch mal in den Kühlschrank
ich hatte die Torte über Nacht im
Kühlschrank weil es mir gestern doch zu
spät wurde und außerdem ist immer besser
wenn buttercremetorten gut gekühlt sind
dann könnt ihr sie wunderbar dekorieren
guck mal ich hatte sie auch einfach mit
einem Tortenring abgedeckt also
drumherum gestellt ohne dass er die
Torte berührt und dann eben über Nacht
gekühlt
jetzt setze ich die Torte auf eine
Tortenplatte
und die Buttercreme die hatte ich
einfach über Nacht
hier in der Küche stehen
das heißt die sitzt nicht kalt sondern
lag hier einfach kühl aber also der Raum
hier ist nicht so warm wenn jetzt einen
richtig warmen Heizungen Raum habt dann
vielleicht nicht in der Küche lagern
aber wenn ihr vielleicht sowas wieder
Abstellkammer habt wo es einfach etwas
kühler ist dann einfach dort abstellen
die geht dann auch nicht kaputt denn die
Eier sind pastorisiert die Butter
überlebt auch bei Raumtemperatur also da
passiert gar nichts über Nacht
deine Macke reingemacht
und diese Macke
ich habe hier eine kleine Macke seht ihr
sie
ich mache das einfach so
ich habe auch eine Macke nicht nur die
Torte
sieht kein Mensch
ich finde es auch tatsächlich richtig
schön dass die Oberfläche nicht ganz so
perfekt glatt ist das gehört so
okay dann dekoriere ich jetzt mal die
Torte ich habe hier jetzt noch mal die
den Fruchtaufstrich dann habe ich hier
ein paar
schokoladendekorationen die so ein
bisschen
Glimmer haben und Glimmer haben Glitzer
wie heißen Glanz
Blaubeeren orange Sternanis und die
Cranberries die ich bereits gezuckert
und getrocknet habe gut ich weiß nicht
genau wie sie aussehen soll aber jetzt
schneide ich erstmal die Orangenscheiben
aber ich dachte das passt alles gut
zusammen
ja so eine Scheibe und davon dann
so halbe Scheiben und Fette
[Musik]
gerade das Muster so krass also hier
sieht man ja so richtig wie eine Orange
typischerweise aussieht aber ich finde
hier am Anfang guckt euch das mal an
wie so ein tolles Muster
richtig schön
dann habe ich ja hier diese Lochtülle
und damit setze ich einfach ein paar
Tupfer hier drauf und ich mache das
ganze aber nicht so symmetrisch also ich
versuche schon den Großteil der Deko
hier hinten zu machen und dann kann ich
vielleicht die Marmelade ein bisschen
erwärmen den Fruchtaufstrich und kann
dann so ein bisschen das ganze so
runterdrücken lassen
also lass da einfach eure Kreativität
freien Lauf
es wird jetzt nur eine Herausforderung
es nicht symmetrisch zu machen
ich kann es aber auch
machen dann nehme ich jetzt hier einfach
die Deko und setzt sie einfach
wunderschön hier drauf oh vielleicht
nehme ich noch ein bisschen süßen Schnee
am Ende zum zum drauf streuen das ist so
ein bisschen Schneekristalle sind
im Sternanis finde ich passt einfach
auch super
den sollte man nicht mitessen aber er
lässt sich gut dekorieren
[Musik]
ich weiß was ich noch mache
ich mache jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
von Fruchtaufstrich auf die Palette
und mache hier so den Rand
schöner Effekt hier
noch ein zwei Orangenscheiben hier
Schnee
und fertig ist meine adventstorte oder
die Weihnachtstorte wenn ihr so wollt
dann räume ich jetzt hier auf und dann
kann gleich probiert werden
[Musik]
heute hole ich jetzt mal wieder den
besten tortenvercosta der Welt dazu der
wahrscheinlich in seinem Leben die
meisten Torten bisher schon probiert hat
Murat es ist gesagt wenn ich mit dem
Garten die ganze Zeit gemacht habe ja
ich bin gerade im Garten und ja ich
probiere es gleich ich muss gleich
wieder raus okay ich nehme mal ein Stück
auf den Gummi mit was denkt ja darfst du
was denkst du wie viele Torten hast du
bisher seit wir zwei verheiratet sind
schon probiert ich weiß nur dass ich 30
Kilo zugenommen habe verheiratet sind
schon einige Torten gewesen sein
aber ihr dürft auch nicht mehr denken
dass das bei uns jeden Tag trocken gibt
es ist nur ihr seht es auf Youtube und
wir erinnern uns eigentlich schon gesund
dazu müssen sie ich nicht aber ist eine
andere Geschichte gut dann Scheiße an
findest du das so eine schöne
Weihnachtstorte richtig schön
weihnachtlich gemacht
was sind das denn das connection
die habe ich gezuckert okay
gefrorene sieht cool aus jetzt macht
dann diesen eis-effekt und ach Gott
jetzt ohne Witz
okay so eine richtig coole Eistorte okay
ohne lebkuchentorte oh nee oder cool
so
okay
also ich probiere jetzt mal
ich probiere auch mal mit Angabe an
wie Lebkuchenherzen
das schmeckt wie Lebkuchen
nicht eiskalt aus dem Kühlschrank
sondern lasst sie so ein bisschen stehen
weil sich dann die Buttercreme da da
entfallet sich der Geschmack besser wenn
die Butter nicht ganz so kalt ist
also ich finde es ein schönes Rezept
probiert es gerne mal aus wie gesagt ist
ein einfaches Rezept finde ich auch ohne
einfache Art und Weise Torten zu
dekorieren und ich wünsche euch noch
einen Wunder wunderschönen
Adventssonntag viel Spaß noch weiterhin
im Adventskalender und viel Spaß beim
backen die ganze Weihnachtszeit
ich würde noch ein bisschen mehr
Marmelade drin ja noch mehr weil die
schmeckt echt cool und dann kommt noch
besser also ein bisschen mehrmals
Marmelade
glaube halbes Glas verwendet dann nimmt
man einfach so ein bisschen mehr ganz
klar
ein bisschen höher spritzen und habe
noch mehr marmeladenfüllung also viel
Spaß beim backen bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss tschüss
ist ruhig langsam ich mache dir noch
einen Kaffee mag stehen
[Musik]